if you would mind putting on that
blindfold okay I will read these aloud
first one three middle-aged daddies
visit California to have a marvelous
time at the beach when they learn that a
nice apartment isn't enough for them to
score with the chicks but soon they find
out how to use the situation to
everyone's benefit student bodies hard
bodies hard bodies all right it's
Halloween Eve and four College friends
plot to kidnap the wife of a wealthy
friend at a costume party by night's end
what started out as a joke has become a
terrifying nightmare the clown murders
that is absolutely
I don't think you're gonna get this one
I'm going to say it's the Earl ozenby
film Rottweiler it is dogs of Hell
let me see that one for a second yeah
you can have that now one of the uh who
directed this
oh that was the original title the
original title was called Rottweiler